today's question comes from Jordan in
California I have a fully funded
emergency fund of $10,000
wondering where to park it that's
currently in a savings account making
half a percent knowing that money
markets bring very little interest or
should I park it with another online
bank who gives one point two five to one
point four interest with no transfer or
service fees that's fine yeah you should
be able to get up a little over one on
$10,000 now the thing that and it's good
to be thinking about that Jordan the
thing to remember mainly about an
emergency fund is this on $10,000 1% is
$100 1/2 a percent is $50 okay it's not
the purpose of your emergency fund now
if you could get 11% instead of 1% we'd
have something to talk about but we're
talking about 50 bucks so go get the 50
bucks you're handing me 50 bucks I'll
take it okay but it's not gonna change
your life and the point of me bringing
that up is your emergency fund is not an
investment everybody say it with me not
an investment your emergency fund is
insurance you know what insurance does
it costs you money it doesn't make you
money
why do you buy insurance if it costs you
money because it covers your but when
things go bad that's why you buy
insurance it's what your emergency fund
is for it covers your but when things go
bad it's not there to make you rich it's
there to protect other things that will
make you rich because if you have a 401
K and you don't have an emergency fund
and you get laid off from your job you
know what you'll do to pay your house
payment and feed your kids
you'll cash out your 401 K and they'll
hit you for a 10% interest or 10%
penalty plus your tax rate so
get a 35 or 45 percent yet because you
didn't have an emergency fund and you
cash out your 401k which was there to
make you rich by the way the number one
way that people become millionaires
these days is their 401k if you didn't
know number one way you're at retirement
investing so now now so what's this mean
it means that the $10,000 is there to
keep you from cashing out stuff or
selling off stuff at pennies on the
dollar I've got all my money in real
estate good you know what real estate
that sells really fast is because you're
in a hurry because you're in an
emergency you know what they call real
estate that sells fast cheap you have to
give it a way to turn it into money so
you don't sell real estate fast you want
to be in a position of strength when
you're selling real estate not a
position of weakness same thing with
your investments right so your
investments are protected by your rainy
day fund so your emergency fund as a
financial planning tool is not an
investment it's insurance it costs you
money because you're making nothing on
it you could have invested it and made
better money on it but you're not gonna
do that because it's there to protect
you to keep rain off of you it's your
rainy day fund for when stuff happens
not if stuff happens because stuff is
gonna happen then you better be ready so
good job getting the $10,000 together
Jordan good job asking the question but
always keep in mind always remember that
the main reason for your emergency fund
is for insurance it's not an investment
so go put it in a money market make an
extra $50 that's all good there's no
problem with that I'm not making fun of
you for asking that question but I am
reminding everybody that see when you
get to baby step 3 and you finally have
no debt you finally have $10,000 in your
emergency fund you really want the money
to work hard because you've worked so
hard to get to that point but all you've
done then is lay the foundation when
you're building a house you're building
a building laying the foundation takes
forever but then it goes fast from the
the walls get stood up it goes building
just goes right straight up right and
that's what's gonna happen with your
wealth now if you'll leave the
foundation in place but what if as soon
as you got the foundation in place you
pulled it out and then you tried to
build the walls without the foundation
that would be dumb that's why we have
this emergency fund it's a it's a
building block in your foundation so
always remember folks it is your
insurance policy it is not your
investment so make as much as you can
make on it but for if you look at it as
an investment you will forever be
aggravated by it you'll forever be mad
about it I do not even know what the
rate is on the money market in my
emergency fund last year I did not look
at it it is such a small percentage of
my net worth in my overall world today
it doesn't matter it's not there to make
me rich other stuff is doing that thank
you very much